hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to darkwood it's been a
couple days since the last time i played
and we made it barely
through a night very uh uh challenging
to say the least some goodies here i was
gonna do the whole
lighting a fire routine now i'm
beginning to think that maybe molotovs
would just be better
i can't seem to get that for some reason
so i'm gonna go around
oh god
okay the bear trap also did nothing it
didn't help me at all
it's kind of a waste all right perfect
it's good is there like a way to
cycle through the different uh things on
the ground
is there is there a way is there there's
gotta be a cycle
cycle cycle trap there we go perfect
hey hi how are you doing
all oh let's take this knife real quick
hi
the three okay hi
oh hi lovely sack you have there
the three visitors stare at me in
silence as if waiting
for my move i can only hear the heavy
breathing of the tallest figure
holding a giant bag as the tallest
figure opens the bag the room is filled
with an
intense smell of mushrooms apparently
they wish to give me something
oh good you're the traders now
great thank you for coming i did need
this
i think i don't think i need the fabric
anymore because i'm pretty sure i'm
maxed out on both of those unless
there's a way to get more but
as for now i don't really know so i'm
gonna make some i'm gonna make some
calls
the pills the running pills i don't
really use those i got the ability i got
the super speeds in my legs um
i don't need a kitchen knife that's for
sure this is
wonderful you have so much reputation
thank you by the way
you are so beautiful with your face
and your face and your face i'll take
the mush
i'll take the this the that it seems
like there's a lot of chests in this
area i'm gonna definitely explore
the zone i'm gonna explore everything i
have this hunting rifle is that for the
medium caliber bullet is that what that
is i mean i have the money so i might as
well right
i also need to get like a lay of the
land of how much stuff i have i've kind
of forgotten okay 427 that's good
hey uh where was my workbench it was
over here it's a work bench what can i
make
i can make a shotgun that would probably
be pretty good
uh let me let me cook the thing first i
bought a mush
oh 1280. oh efficiency oh all right cool
i've got plenty of pistol ammo though so
i definitely should use those
i should dump the gas that i have into
the generator wherever that be where i
forgot where the generator is
where is it there it is okay i can turn
that off now
i don't need it at the moment uh hitting
the tank will release the gas under high
pressure
i don't really need that i don't want
that either i feel like that's just
gonna blow up and i'm gonna die so i'm
gonna
trade those in but maybe it would be
good to set up some
ah but i'll die i will die i put maybe i
but i'll die
i know i will i'll die i will
my god okay i'll take him how about the
shotgun what did that need it needed
tape
a weapon part and uh something else
uh i might not be able to make it right
now but eventually i could work towards
it
okay the barrel gun parts and then tape
to make a shotgun that sounds pretty
good but i don't know if i have enough
stuff to give
for that i'm gonna have to hold off
let's put away the hunting rifle for now
let's keep the pistol because i have
that ammo i really should try to use the
axe
more than that oh okay so there's a
there's a slow attack and there's a
quick attack
that'll be helpful i probably should use
it but the shovel has such good reach i
love the shovel
the shovel's so good all right whatever
you know what i'm gonna
leave this like here drop is that how
you do it
how do you do it then oh it must just be
like a bear trap or something
i could shoot it with a pistol and then
like kabumi that'd be good right
that's the objective right i'm like you
won't get me
this time and then they all die ah
fine i'll keep the shovel i'm just gonna
do shovel i like shovel
shovel's cool shovel is good i like
shovel this light's on
why is this light on it's not spooky
mode
it's not spooky it's not spooky enough
right that's better
so what i need to do is i need to really
explore
this place cottage near the junkyard i
don't know what that means
okay but i need to really explore this
area and i mean really explore it
because i feel like the last area that i
was in i didn't get
i didn't get nearly enough of the things
that were available
[Music]
what the a hell of a man wearing a
helmet his head has been severed
key to the underground
a weird book
[Music]
is that my friend no
he tried to come find me
[Music]
no no
no oh my god that's horrible
oh my god i left him behind i left him
behind
god damn it i didn't even think about
him oh
god and you are now that's god
[Music]
i didn't even think about it of course
god damn it he tried to come find me and
i
let him i i left him behind to die oh
that makes me
so sad all right i'm sorry i gotta get
moving i know but
man that actually hurts that actually
hurts
i'll sell the gap i don't know what the
gas bottle is for highly flammable gas
it's probably something you throw
and then a match it's like a molotov but
not quite i'd rather just make a molotov
let's just chuck this for now let's not
buy the shotgun stuff because i don't
know if i'm gonna get a shotgun
thing you know i might they might just
like i might find it here because maybe
i was supposed to find it in the last
one and i didn't
because i'm an idiot and i went too far
too fast so i'll just leave them with
reputation but god that sucks
it's time to go sad enough pussyfooting
around we gotta explore but
these woods are dangerous wait before i
go i don't have a light source
dumb ass me i don't have bottles oh
i have a lantern with me i had one on me
the whole time i forgot that's all right
okay let's go let's do this explore
everything
oh yeah there's a chest there oh
yeah oh yeah buddy
oh buddy what's going on there
hole i don't like the meat hole
[Applause]
found a ruin okay well that's good
there's probably stuff in the ruin
freaking frick i hate that thing
what is with you
what is that
[Music]
what the what
the happened
what did i just see what happened
i don't know i don't know
okay oh my god it killed a dog and then
exploded
oh my god okay i need to uh i see what i
need to do
i see don't worry i'm smart i'm smart
i'm smart scarred for life of course but
very smart
okay looking at you hey thanks
thanks bud oh
god
i'm not your mommy i think we have
guests ah
who's your mama who's your mama
i don't trust mom i don't trust mama
mama mama mama oh god mama oh mama
mama mama please oh i can't get through
i can't get through how do i get through
oh god mama this was a mistake i'm stuck
in here oh god i'm stuck
i didn't think this through ah what do i
have do i have anything that i can burn
you with i don't
ah get out get out of me
get out of me oh god hold the babies oh
the babies
okay just shoot the baby shoot him shoot
him shoot him i'm out of bullets
shoot him shoot him shoot him bang
your mom sucks babies never have
anything
i don't know why the baby's even uh have
a lootable option
oh thanks for the lantern that's
actually helpful thank you
oh god this what the hell there's so
much stuff
so much good stuff here oh pliers oh my
god i need those
someone make a markiplier joke i can
come back for the bottles later the
wood's good but
all that i can come back for but i i
need to
look at this guy in the eye so i can get
all this stuff to close down
hey bud how you doing is there something
wait what
what is in front of me what am what am i
looking at oh it's nothing
oh then why oh i need to shine it and
then run right right right
i can make it if i'm quick this eye's a
little more sensitive you know what i
mean
all right go go go go go go go go go go
hey all right good
great love that place this is just
delightful
every part of this is so delightful
that's just all i can say about shiny
stone oh hell yeah all right
ah you know i'll just go cook the things
that i have okay put that away
upgrade i need more wire there might
have been more in there i've gotta
i'm gonna i'm gonna organize this later
don't worry that there put that there
okay go cook the stuff i have
this is great though this is a ton of
good stuff
and i mean i know it's probably just
because this this world is gonna be
insanely
difficult but they're giving me lots of
good stuff
and i like good stuff shiny stone that
is some good stuff that is stuff that i
can sell
hello i've come for your things how you
doing bud
you doing good good good to see
flashlight
okay good oh i should have dropped off
the pliers
okay so this nightmare obviously came
out of the ground here
which is awful so that's a new trap that
i have to keep an eye out for
and they blow up apparently so that's
terrible
like of all the ways that like in in
movies games things
just blowing up like that i hate it i
hate it
more than anything i'm taking this nice
and slow
oh i don't like it what are you what are
you what are you
what are you what are you what are you
what are you i don't want to
dig okay sure yeah all right this seems
safe yeah this is good
i'll dig why not i think i kept that
shovel on me
oh oh it was actually good oh
i don't want any of it oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god
oh my god oh my god oh my god ow you
threw an army ow you're right there holy
crap
i hate you so much
uh i'm full again of stuff i gotta go
back
again i've gone two inches in this game
in this new map
and i i have everything in existence
forever maybe
maybe there's a way i could i don't have
to cross through the swamp maybe i can
get cut up through here
looks like it yeah that would have been
easier i'm an idiot and now the rain
yeah you know actually rain
that's it makes sense do it lay it up on
me just rain
why is it crying what's crying here i
don't know uh let's cook it and go out
real quick we have probably time for one
more
true trip and then we gotta start
start sheltering uh man almost had
enough my goodness
i'll go this way now oh don't trust that
here i go
all right you know worked out maybe i
should trust more
maybe i'm being a little silly not
trusting things
i gotta learn to trust again open my
heart up to
possible failure i probably gotta what i
gotta do in this area especially
in the night is just plan way better
on traps bear traps like
layouts i need paths to run i think it
might actually be better not to
barricade
absolutely everything because what i
need to do is i need to create
a funnel of space that's going to be
oh hey i didn't think there would be any
savages here
i don't know how you could survive ah i
gotcha
who's oh there's another one who's
slumping their nog
who's doing it oh this is a trap oh this
is a trap oh
hello oh god ah
stupid stupid stupid stupid stupid
oh this is weird what's going on
oh my god
okay yeah that's fine oh
yeah that's fine that's perfectly fine
okay yeah i've gone
two inches all these woods are dense
oh hey i found a ton of
really valuable items stuff that i could
sell for
whoa it's fine
it's fine can i please get out of these
nests of
trees oh my god is oh my god
oh there's no way out oh god
i'm trapping myself yeah if this was a
trap where
enemies were going to come after me that
would have been perfect i would ah guys
yeah hey where are you where are you
where are you
where where where i s i heard you i
didn't see you but i heard you
which is practically seeing oh it's one
of those things oh god
don't oh oh oh oh oh i hate it oh god
ah why both of you both of you go away
oh no
no no no no no not again i gotta eat
this
no oh poison bathroom oh god oh god okay
i'm gonna shoot you
you what happened what happened nope
nope got that two of you
gotta take a bullet in the head
and i gotcha oh frick
me in the head honk
okay
i'm going home i i've been
i've been good jesus get off of me
get off me how do i get off get off of
me
how do i how what do i do what do i do
what do i do
oh my god i hate this place
i hate it i hate this place i hate
everything in it i hate this place i
hate these things
i hate everything about it there's
apparently logs here but i don't care
i'm full not again no no no you
freaking go ah
of course that would happen of course
that's what they do they blow up
i am an idiot of course they blow up
i'm going home please no swamp creatures
for the love of god no swamp creatures
just let me get home
please that is awful this is awful oh
my friend is dead i hate everything
about this everything that's happening
right now
is awful and the worst thing and i have
so much crap
which is uh good but also like oh my god
it's nuts uh i still don't have enough
to upgrade and i need to buy that
tomorrow i'm gonna make some molotov
cocktails
for tonight because i think i'm gonna
need them board and
nails where did they go where'd they go
where i don't i need to organize this
nails i only have that many nails i only
have 19 nails shoot
uh let's repair my shovel let's
pull out more bullets for tonight i
guess we'll try to put down the other
gas
tank it'll probably blow me up more than
it'll blow them up but
hey whatever i'll try at least oh i'm
gonna get a vision
oh there we go i deal double damage in
melee when close to death my vitality
will increase
once a day i will become invisible to
enemies if i stay still
i forgot i had these abilities i
completely forgot about my abilities
well i don't want my accuracy to be
decreased definitely no if i increase my
vitality
like if the bandages they heal for a
long period of time so over time i feel
like that would be
good i'll get the vitality and
the weak regeneration that seems fine
i'll just eat more wood
silly so i need to plan my route um
let's put
one of these right here i'll run past it
and then
blast it okay good good good good cause
i won't die instantly if i go outside
the range
of the house i think uh let's play some
bear traps that i can try to
run people through maybe in in this room
here if i'm
running this way if i come in here and
then i place like a bear trap
here i can run around it if i remember
which i hope i remember
place one there and then go
okay that's a dumb that would be a
terrible move to do go here
i can run through here i probably
shouldn't go over that way
you know now that i'm thinking about it
that might be a bad idea going over that
way
uh god this oh i'm running out of time
okay oh but
i gotta leave it god damn it i forgot
that if i pick it up it turns into not a
bear trap
okay whatever it's fine okay so there's
light in there i need to keep a lantern
on me through the night i think i'm
gonna go ahead and switch to the good
lantern
i got another bear trap here let's put
it right around right on this corner
here
so i can i can go wide and then come
around it and i should be okay
do i have anything else uh that was i
did i i'm out of cookable the well the
well the well i need the well cause i
need to heal
well build build now now drink drink
okay
oh god i don't have healing items on me
i'm out of pills
i forgot the pills oh my god it's time
okay uh pills i only have one
great i i need more of these okay
molotovs
uh gun ammo okay yeah
all right oh my god oh my god who's
there
who's there who's there who's there
who's there who's there who's there try
me try me
try me try me try me try me
oh that is god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god go on my trap go on
my trap here
oh my god go on my trap here yeah yeah
and
oh my god oh what the
yeah yeah ow
ow ow okay you dead
okay okay
i didn't run at all i didn't run i've
completely forgot about the gas
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god i'm gonna blow you
ah i'm gonna blow you i'm gonna blow you
you're gonna get blown you're gonna get
blown
you're gonna get blown watch this you're
gonna get blown you're blown
no you're in the way all right i blowed
you anyway
good reload
i think i handled that nicely perfectly
calm
collected that's how i do
oh oh not this not this not this knock
oh no
no no no you go back you go back you go
back you go back
you go back now you stay you stay right
there
you stay right there no no no
sassy lamp you lamp stop fighting me
lamp stop fighting me lamp
you go back you go back in your hole go
back in your position so you
oh no i don't want to go i didn't press
vault i didn't press it
give me
oh that's definitely a thing that's a
thing you're in you're in
yeah yeah yeah yeah try me
try me
get wrecked i should have been using my
pistol a little more
five o'clock is easy it's just three
shots for those things to die that's not
too bad
yeah here comes the music okay
good all right great oh my god i don't
think anything else is gonna come
tiny stone shiny stone shiny stone lots
of shiny stone
bolt handle probably can sell that the
knife uh i can make armor
do that should have done that probably
[Music]
whoa
we've done it hey
i still don't like you that much take
all of this stuff please
oh i need to buy something from you i
need the wire that's what i needed
great thank you take care now go away
god every time i hate you so much i hate
you so much
okay love it love it
okay i can upgrade workshop yep
oh hunting rifle must be really good
then i should use it
it must be really good it's gotta be
right i'm gonna use it
maybe it takes the medium caliber
magazine or maybe it's a medium caliber
bullet
i don't know but if it's like a one shot
one kill that
that'd be really dope as hell oh i have
another shiny stone in there
let's change out to this and also oh you
can combine them oh
i didn't know that oh hell yeah well
that's very useful oh the flashlight i
can sell that
flares i'm gonna keep uh actually no i'm
actually over so i can sell those
i need nails i need wood
i need the basics that's what i don't
have okay basics basics basics basics i
need the basics
uh except that this maybe the bullet i'm
thinking maybe
flares flashlight stick pills
i do want the shotgun eventually i mean
i could get it right now
but i should use the hunting rifle well
what else am i going to spend it on you
know what actually what else am i going
to spend it on because if i can get the
other barrel maybe i can go for the
double barrel shotgun
and that would be pretty sweet all right
let me see if i can make it seems almost
weird to think about using guns here now
let's go
single shot shotgun let's go that it
still has half the value of the rifle
the rifle must be just
dope what i'm gonna do is actually i'm
gonna make some
bandages with alcohol because now my
healing's gonna be less effective and i
don't have nearly enough
wood to start munching on it the whole
time so i'm gonna carry my
hunting rifle and i'm gonna either carry
a medium caliber magazine or a medium
caliber bullet
and i'm gonna see which one it needs and
actually i'm gonna forgo the pistol just
because i want to save inventory
uh cause i'm gonna need to go okay we're
good we're still exploring we've barely
covered everything we're gonna go past
the wood piles and we're gonna go
further beyond and then we're gonna
shoot something with this gun
and it's gonna die hopefully and if it
doesn't die then i'm gonna
ask for my money back because i i was
promised a dead creature and
i did not get it maybe that might be the
future
i don't know if that is the future but
that might be
oh it's you the vines i'm going for this
one here
did i trust it for some reason oh good i
should oh god it's the be
i go oh i could have god
every time it's fine it's fine
uh anymore no actually i'm okay for now
god look at all this good stuff so this
is where all the
wood is so this is the wood area so i'll
come back for this when i need
more wood which will be soon
don't trust that another hole
odd looking me how am i full already i'm
full already good god what is what am i
looking at
junkyard oh okay
you know what actually i'm gonna put on
my lantern i don't want anything
sneaking up on me
oh hi hello you okay you all right
doctor oh it's the doctor oh you again
what do you want from me want to put me
in front of a firing squad for desertion
the doctor snorts ironically hiding his
irritation i'm not going anywhere with
you
i'm too close i can hear her just as if
she was standing beside me
my little with shaking hands he reaches
for the cigarette butt between his
yellow teeth
i'm sure someone is waiting for you too
he spits out the rest of the tobacco
oh i can trade with you why are you
showing this to me you better tell me
how to get there
i used to come here to treat people i
pulled out kids milk teeth delivered
babies
and then came the diseases i've never
even heard of i was the only doctor in
the area
you cut us off from the outside world
first you then the woods
no help from anyone last time i came
here was three or four years ago
then the trees blocked the path the
doctor looks around the area
it's different now the fields are
flooded everyone in the village is dead
so much work for nothing some of the
flooded areas hide underwater passages
recently i fell into this underwater den
in the western edge of the swamp i have
no idea where it leads
i'm a shitty diver i've seen a similar
one in the northeastern edge of the
swamp i realized something it came to me
when we were walking through the tunnels
you're like a disease you and your kind
the doctor takes a step back as if he
was afraid of me
at the same time a sinister smile
appears on his face you don't belong to
this land
you weren't here when the forest was
born you're a splinter a foreign body
a vagabond and them the forest and
everything else here these are the
antibodies
even the morons from the village raging
white blood cells in an infected
bloodstream
that's the reason you hide from us the
doctor is visibly pleased with himself
in his theory
his hands are no longer trembling he
produces a hand-rolled cigarette and
lights it
logical isn't it sure the peasants broke
through the wall of trees i couldn't
believe my eyes
i tried to do it many times i couldn't
manage to cut the trees fast enough it
was as if the woods were healing the
scars
the were growing right
back in front of my eyes i was afraid i
would get stuck between the trunks
losing that sow made their blood run
cold they escaped
fearing starvation the doctor smiles as
he puffs a cigarette
out of the frying pan and into the fire
they have a camp in the old quarry in
the southeastern edge of the swamp
yeah wow holy they made it that's
nuts
i i also like i shouldn't have traded
every oh
what what do you buy what oh that's
weird
okay i don't like that all right cool
well there's something also there's
something on your face
which is very bizarre i'm gonna dig
apparently
hello oh that's
fabric what the hell the valuable yeah
valuable very valuable
okay all right um there's another one
oh there's a whole bunch of them okay
well another barrel
i never should have bought it i guess i
really shouldn't have bought it
do i have enough for this one too yes i
do
oh what the frick
what the hell
i will wave to you when i'm on my way to
where no man has been before
this guy made it why he didn't make it
but his rocket
what i don't know what to believe
anymore i i don't i don't know what
how what how what in the war i gotta go
back
okay you know what there's too much i
gotta go back
okay they made it good good for them
good for them i think
what there's some footprints on the
floor yeah there are what the hell
what the hell what the hell
what the hell wait where did it come
from first
just oh yeah okay yeah okay yeah okay
yeah okay locked oh yeah
yeah okay that's fine that is really
fine yeah that's fine
i don't see why i'm so worried there's
nothing to worry about that's fine
and definitely tonight that will be
still fine okay i need to repair my
shovel okay got it
all right that's all the time i have for
this episode of darkwood
what the hell is even happening
i don't know but i'll find out soon so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think down in the
comments below and as always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]